my name is natalie i'm a designer at
Nomo we design bags and accessories that
organize your life yeah yeah okay so
what what is are you allowed to reveal
what the upcoming moods are what's going
to be the mood for early 2017 because
we're late 2016 and the current mood is
just desperation and disaster and
everything is going to be awful will it
be kind of post-apocalypse
because again as a gentleman
I've always felt quite not in the loop
when it comes to banks because it's kind
of you know you dad had a briefcase and
then I had a rucksack when I was at
school you know what's the kind of the
classic bag what's the bag to end all
banks that's what we delve into you know
what situation where because you won't
take the same bag to a festival that you
take to work just yeah I should not have
done that no wonder I got laughter yeah
yeah personally oh yeah you still got
your hands if you didn't have arms
you couldn't worry about that so how did
you get it home
so this is this choose any pro award
late 2000 mid-2000s I had a hiking
backpack with a chest clip and a waist
clip I still managed to carry 50
kilograms of weight on my back 6-month n
rations for a group of 5 meet us poor
girls because we were a mixed group and
I was boys trekking group because my
favorite bag is the bag of Mary Poppins
the conveyancing yeah which I guess is
you know what you guys trying to do but
in a real practical environment and not
just a backwards on top of a chest with
a hole with a prop mending it because
that's how it was done spoiler sorry to
ruin Mary Poppins for you also she can't
actually flying do it we'll do a wrap
and do wrap time then again this Sam
let's do it yeah yeah organization
backpacks and commuting and the
underground let's do this y'all let me
flow slippery lag Lube going down TfL
under London tube on the ground above
the tracks when I see all it inhabited
by rats but they never we're thinking me
back I'm like y'all little vermin get a
backpack but a rat backpack would not
fit on the arms be too heavy no it
causing harm it's like a false alarm
when it weigh in on the span wanna get a
backpack as reflective as man when I
reflect back on my school days had a
little backpack we know the craze was to
draw on it get respect do a band logo
with the putter tip X you can go down
there stitch with a suture want to get
my backpack the commuters the Darcy has
unfortunately seems everybody like y'all
we're also
for you to put the backpack between your
legs make sure we got it down there
below your head so you take less face
less q big feet
got a nice backpack it is so neat and if
you want to get it down below you're
fast make sure your backpack is
organized is so cool when every place
got a place put it down there yet hold
it to your face like put my phone in the
pocket with the zip put my wallet in the
pocket on my hip gotta make sure that it
goes where it goes getting all the
padding on I keep that close maybe it's
secured with a padlock or combination
otherwise I get that frustration when
things get muddled of the bottom of the
bag I've been like oh no the Strad
stutter sag can't find things have to
rummage around you pick it up what is
this I found just some old chewing gum
drop it out the zip mesh horrible yeah
because it's such a mesh and that is how
commuters survive wear a nice backpack
and organized yes that's a good mime
club that means that yes I think so I
think so I think so we're back thanks
guys back literally a backpack rap like
literally Kanye's literally Kanye yeah
you said be a long proper Kanye people
say can you rap I say can I
finished it dead on my [ __ ] hand God
never even rest on a big four